worst date i ever been on
um
it's kind of unofficial it was like i
was kind of playing a wingman to my
friend
um
this is when i was in junior college
back in texas
and
my boy jaron from new york
uh we were near like texas tech
campus and he was talking to a girl from
there and
he
you know he made plans to link up with
her
uh and she was like oh do you have a
friend for my girlfriend
and
he was like
yeah so he hits me up he's like yo let's
go out tonight like i got a girl for you
or something and i was like all right
bet like what does she look like
um i don't know and the important the
the most important question so he sends
me like pictures that clearly she sent
him to send me i don't know and you know
how like how you know she sent it to
yeah
you ever asked a girl like to to send
pics of yourself or something sorry can
you hear me all right you ever asked a
girl to like send pics of yourself yeah
and she's sending pictures that clearly
are like only like her best angles okay
yeah you can't get like a clear it's
never like a straight on
it was like [ __ ] like that yeah okay and
so already i'm like
[Music]
uh like she looked she looked good but
then she didn't i was going back and
forth yeah i was trying to be there for
my boy because the wingman role is
important right it's a support
this is support y'all play video games
hey support characters are crucial i'm
just a poor character tonight
and
i was like i like playing battlefield
yeah but i was like it's no pressure
like i don't have to do nothing you know
what i'm saying i'm just there to
mingle yeah just mingle yeah bro
um so we go to this club i was like all
right so we go to this club we always go
too i forget the name
uh
we're chilling there for a while then he
he hits me up he's like yo the girls are
outside let's go get him
we get him we go outside
and immediately i see the girl that i'm
set up with in my heart
was she heavier
like
i knew she was like
she was a thicker woman and i don't got
no problem with that like she was cur
like if you curvy like i don't mind
extra pounds
i don't mind like if you thick
but she was like the wrong kind of thick
and
this knife pissed me off so much i can
say this no problem like she was built
like a melted ice cream cone that's what
she was built like know
and
i looked at my boy i was like come on
bro you set me up and he he looked at me
because he knew he [ __ ] up he was like
i've been in that situation
i've been in that
situation i've been like a situation
yeah so
and me and her lock eyes and she's like
you know you're like [ __ ] no i'm like
yeah oh my gosh i had to wing woman for
someone
oh y'all do that too yeah didn't yeah
actually yeah they do yeah they do they
do oh my gosh you know i actually i have
set people up so because i've always
been like you know i have this show
right now people meet through the show
like like all the time right but outside
of that i've just always been the person
that like knows people because i'm
always like throwing stuff or like i
just i just always been my part like
yeah
yeah yeah um
so this um
yeah no the other i can't tell never
mind
yeah
i thought
it was about to be something me and him
doing it
all right
so you're i'm really supporting
[Music]
so
they immediately dip he goes with his
girl
i guess they made playing he was about
to smash that night
oh so he they dipped off it was lying
and dancing yeah the girl grabs my hand
the girl i'm supposed to get with just
grabs me by the hand and is like
let's get some drinks i'm like [ __ ] i'm
gonna need something to get through
tonight so
we go to the bar
she's like what do you like to drink i'm
like
i don't know honey and coke i was like
honey and coke
and then she goes uh
okay great go to the bartender let me
get six henny and coke [ __ ] she knew she
was ugly
and the bartender's looking at me he's
like
so
you know he goes against the drinks i'm
like i'm looking at her she's like i got
it pulls out the card
um i'm like
all right she's trying to get me [ __ ]
up so
so she get the drinks we get the drinks
she's not even trying to like go in the
general population she's like let's go
out back to like this little patio area
where no one is so we're sitting there
she's like sitting next to me trying to
talk i'm like mentally like gone i'm
trying to like not
talk to her but not be a dick at the
same time
and
she's like oh drink your drink and
you know i crushed too quick
um and then we're just kind of like kind
of having a surface level combo
um
and i was like ah thanks for the drinks
um and you know
i don't know if anyone here is from
london the u.s
the drinking age legal drinking age is
21. i was like 20 at the time so i was
like oh thanks for the drinks like
you know i couldn't have got it because
they knew i was underage so they put a
big x on my hand so i couldn't get
drinks so i'm like i got this x on my
hand and she's like
oh we got to get rid of that takes my
hand
no way licks it no way i need to know
what it is my hand like it was so gross
okay number one you use a ponytail and
water okay it's like wait what
what
what happened
yeah yeah if to get the x off you use a
ponytail like if you put your like
that's how you we would get him off wait
wait
i know i'm saying like she she didn't
have to like oh
yeah
look she licks my she licks my hand
like trying to be sexy like staring me
in the eyes oh no and then my hand's
just like wet now i'm just like
i was so like stuck so i'm just sitting
here in my hand like it's like a dog
just just lick your hand
i was like is this happening and then
she's like wiping it off right there i
was like i gotta get out of here
she's trying to talk to me and then i'm
just like
sorry excuse me
all of a sudden i was just like you know
what this is a mistake
she's like what
and her eye kind of twitched for a
second oh she's crazy she's like what
i said this is a mistake
i shouldn't have come here i said i
gotta go
i stood up and she was like no way come
back like no please
[Applause]
and i started walking back into the club
to find my bro she's like following me
like no come on come back like you
didn't even finish your drinks like
trying to get me more [ __ ] up she was
probably gonna spike i was scared bro
and she's like no like we can like no
like just come with me like we can have
a good time
i find my brows like brother saying it
like i can't do this
he's like come on bro like just give me
like i was like no no like yeah you set
me up bro
like i've been through so much
uh so he ends up you know his girl ends
up having to leave i guess i ruined his
night oh no [ __ ] it damn right you
didn't you're a terrible wingman no like
she was harassing me and then she kept
me
she kept following me i turned around i
was like stop following me like you're
making this weird like you're begging go
away
and i felt mean oh my yes i can't even
imagine having to beg for that oh my god
and then as it goes
you can get that so easy oh my god they
left and we me and him stayed at the
club
and i was like bro like please like you
secured it right and he was like yeah
i'm good like you know he's still gonna
get hit
so i'm just trying to have a good time
my phone starts blowing up and she's
texting me how's she getting her number
bro
probably him oh he's like
he's doing anything to get his cheeks so
so she's blowing my phone up
oh just come to the car
baby please come to the car i can baby
like pretty much saying like she
she's trying to smash in the car like
all this stuff i'm like
did you go though
come on
don't play with me
i have self-respect like you had like
six i was just wondering no she got sick
i didn't talk to you that's the thing i
drank two real quick because i was kind
of like
you know maybe this will make the night
go smoother but then i realized she
wasn't drinking anything she was really
trying to get me faded yeah yeah and
that's when i felt
you know what i felt like
i was like this must be what women feel
like
guys kind of like
i like to go i felt like the [ __ ] yeah
yeah
i was being you weren't trying to say
that but yeah yes it was scary i felt
violated oh my god especially when she
licked my hand when she looked my hand i
knew it was over i have oh my gosh the
worst is when you tell like i know when
he gets mad that is like wait what
happened i'm gonna know because
sometimes you tell me you tell me you
tell guys no and they like get angry i'm
like i'm not a hooker
you guys told me it was it was a g
or gabby i don't know but one of you
told me like some guy like you said no
some guy and he started getting mad and
started throwing some [ __ ]
oh no that wasn't me you know the
instance i'm thinking of is like
i told this guy no and then he was like
he's like well you're such a [ __ ] i
can't believe you won't be like
i don't understand because i don't know
and i was like i don't get it wait
someone said they said if a guy did that
to a girl bought her a heap of drinks
tried to get her drunk and licked her it
would be group yes that's what i'm
saying yes bro of course i didn't and
this is my i was 20 like i wasn't you
that's never happened to me before i was
she was older than me she's old enough
to buy drinks [ __ ] so hey you you she
was scared you were sexually sexually
harassed bro
how did it feel